in the early hours Israeli Special
Forces backed by the Army carried out a
raid in Janine refugee camp the
firefight was intense one Palestinian
fighter 25 year old Adam jabarine was
killed another man unarmed and not a
fighter was also shot dead 57-year-old
Gerard fried was a teacher at a local
school his son describes what happened
israeli's Special Forces entered the
camp at 2 30 a.m they stormed the
building Adam was standing here they
shot him we were dragging him away he
was calling for help ours is the closest
house how could we leave him I opened
the door my father and I we dragged him
in they showed at my father my father
went out to help a wounded man who was
screaming for help
these almost nightly raids across the
occupied West Bank have killed 17
Palestinians this year in Janine refugee
camp many of the residents are people
who were forced from their homes when
Israel created its state in 1948 young
people who have never seen their
ancestral homes frustrated by the lack
of any kind of peace process many of
those young men are now becoming
increasingly hardened a recent opinion
poll suggests 59 percent of Palestinian
respondents supported an armed struggle
against the occupation
we haven't seen such support for an
armed interfada since the last one it's
mainly due to the Israeli policies in
the occupied West Bank increased
settlements killings and raids on a
daily basis the latest Israeli elections
and calls to expel all Palestinians
Israel shows that no signs of stopping
or even reducing raids like these and
this far-right government is openly
hostile to all Palestinians a
combination that has led to violence in
the past this mural commemorates the
armed into fada the Armed struggle in
the year 2000 now many here say another
Reckoning with Israel is coming the only
question is what shape that will take
and that question is being asked with
ever more increasing frequency Imran
Khan Al Jazeera Ramallah